there are 79 known moons of Jupiter what
if we moved earth into its orbit - how
would you Pater's super strong gravity
affect our lives
what would our skies look like and how
long could you survive on a freezing
planet that's full of volcanoes this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the earth was a moon of Jupiter when you
run into an old friend and the last
place you'd expect to see them you
figure it's a small world when you find
out that the planet Jupiter could hold
over 1300 Earth's you realize it's a
tiny world picture this if the earth was
the size of a grape Jupiter would be the
size of a basketball we've got one moon
Jupiter has 79 and Counting
so yeah Jupiter's a big deal and
orbiting it would be a dream for all you
instagramers out there but in this case
a picture doesn't make it last longer
when everyday is a struggle for survival
it's a really really cold morning and
that's because Jupiter is 778 million
kilometers from the Sun that means 25
times less luminosity and 25 times less
heat than we currently enjoy at Earth's
present location
fortunately the Sun is super bright so
we'd still get daylight but if we were
to compare earth to Jupiter's closest
moon Io days would be about 40 hours
long of course that wouldn't really
matter because if you were born on the
earth moon of Jupiter you'd probably
grow up not knowing sunlight the
gravitational pull from Jupiter's other
nearby moons and the planet itself would
generate extreme tidal forces these
would actually generate a lot of heat on
our planet moon
but internally so yeah that's how you
end up in a world where if the cold
doesn't get you then maybe the daily
earthquake tsunami or volcanic eruption
will well either that or you'll just be
cooked to death Jupiter's magnetic field
is ten times stronger than Earth's
meaning that it emits a million times
more radiation so if you really want to
make life on Jupiter's earth moon work
living underground is your best bet one
year on earth is one month on Jupiter
since it takes Jupiter twelve years to
go around the Sun every month on Jupiter
the planet gets hit by about twelve to
sixty comets or asteroids larger small
their impacts are much more
consequential since Jupiter's
gravitational pull accelerates these
objects to a collision speed of about
two hundred and sixteen thousand
kilometers per hour at the minimum if
Earth became one of Jupiter's moons we
are now in the line of fire
has a much much smaller planet we're
less likely to be able to absorb these
kinds of impacts you've done your best
living underground but there's nowhere
left to go when a sizable asteroid
obliterates your home so thanks for
playing better luck next time but really
what did you expect putting a grape
against a basketball that's just cruel
but points to you for style courage and
above all curiosity and keep asking
questions the sky's the limit on what if